buonasera
dopo questa presentazione deve essere
all'altezza ci provo in realtà sono
terrorizzata finire la creatività e
complesso la creatività è una cosa
enorme e potentissima di cui tutti
abbiamo bisogno per sentirci completi
loro detto io ho detto questo signore
questa questo faccione simpatico che il
faccione di bruno munari un uomo che ha
ispirato generazioni di designer di
architetti e ancora oggi continua ad
ispirare chiunque progetti qualcosa gli
architetti bravi dicono dal cucchiaio
alla città ma voi leggete c davvero di
tutto nel mezzo cioè dal costruire la
cuccia del cane fino a costruire un
aquilone e farlo volare qualunque
progetto ha bisogno di una dose
massiccia di creatività questo signore
ha provato a definire la creatività lui
ci ha provato e quando l'ha fatto ha
scritto un tomo di 400 pagine ora è
evidente che a me non è stato concesso
allo stesso tempo magari è solo
questione di tempo non lo so speriamo ma
mi è stato concesso un tempo prezioso in
cui ho voluto scelto di non parlarvi
della creatività nascosta nei gesti dei
grandi architetti
piuttosto pensato di riportare il
racconto su un terreno un pochino più
esperienziale e provare a raccontarvi
una sfumatura della creatività dal punto
di vista di chi come me tutti i giorni o
quasi ha letteralmente i piedi nella
polvere di chi come me
frequenta il cantiere che è un
meraviglioso luogo del fare
in tutti i posti in cui si fa qualcosa
di nuovo io posso usare l'espressione si
costruisce qualcosa di nuovo
letteralmente secondo me la creatività
può essere definita come una competenza
può sembrare una definizione un po
noiosa
gli architetti sono noiosissimi
sappiatelo quando avrete a che fare con
loro ve ne accorgerete
perché dico questo perché se io tolgo
tutto il glamour live tutte quelle
sovrastrutture che spesso sono intorno
alla parola creatività a me nella mia
esperienza resta soltanto qualcosa di
estremamente tangibile qualcosa che io
posso toccare con mano l'architettura
prima ancora di essere una disciplina
stesso vista come una cosa molto lontana
e un processo un processo che non può
non tenere in considerazione delle
regole quelle che l'uomo sedato ma anche
le regole della natura della fisica
della chimica in inevitabilmente la
creatività che accompagna l'architettura
deve fare i conti con queste regole
immaginate la come qualcosa che filtra
che fluisce che si fa davvero spazio tra
paletti che non si possono spostare la
creatività in questo senso è uno
strumento per leggere la realtà per
reinterpretarla mi piace dire che sia
una categoria della possibilità perché
rende le cose possibili
il signor munarin faccione di prima ha
detto ha dato tante definizioni di
creatività ma ce n'è una che mi piace
più di altre dice che la creatività e
una capacità produttiva e per la prima
volta sposta l'attenzione dal momento
dell'ideazione che spesso è confuso con
la creatività al momento in cui qualcosa
si realizza e dice la creatività una
capacità produttiva perché il suo
risultato è sempre qualcosa di nuovo che
si può realizzare che si può fare
ecco io non so se vi ricordate il dottor
frank instinct in frankenstein junior
quando capisce che fa restituire vita al
corpo che ha davanti urla si può fare la
creatività in architettura passo
esattamente per quel si può fare lì
munari tra le tante meravigliose cose
che ho detto ha detto la fantasia vola
alta nel cielo bellissimo la creatività
invece si muove per terra e io mi
permetto di aggiungere striscia
letteralmente nella polvere del cantiere
al punto che non è una cosa che riguarda
solo chi progetta solo che chi è in
qualche modo propulsore di un progetto
ma riguarda estremamente chi fa e qui la
domanda è e allora i creativi chi sono
davvero
probabilmente la risposta più banale
sarebbe quella di citare tutta una serie
di professioni e di figure magari anche
qualche architetto qualche designer ma
sappiamo tutti che la creatività non si
muove in un giardinetto così piccolo
anzi io tra poco vi farò un paio di
esempi e visiterò come brillanti
creativi un muratore di un idraulico
ora io non so se voi avete mai
immaginato a questi artigiani a queste
figure come a dei creativi però sono
abbastanza sicura che quasi tutti voi
abbiate regalato da bambino abbiate
ricevuto quando eravate piccoli i
mattoncini colorati il meccano il banco
da lavoro certamente non barbie ai che
invia architetto che vi invito a cercare
ea trovare una cosa imbarazzante
avete fatto dei regali avete ricevuto
dei regali che servivano per accrescere
la creatività ed è strano che nella vita
di tutti i giorni le professioni che in
qualche modo corrispondono a questi
giochi non siano ritenute creative come
mai perché è davvero così
secondo me ciascuno di noi secondo me e
per fortuna nostra secondo me ciascuno
di noi riceve diciamo alla partenza una
certa dose di creatività e se la porta
in giro all'interno del proprio zainetto
nel proprio viaggio e un po tutti siamo
chiamati ad accrescere la nostra
creatività ad allenarla ad esercitarla
non lo facciamo tutti con lo stesso
spirito con la stessa tenacia quello
stesso desiderio e così alla fine cosa
succede si incontrano persone che dicono
di non essere creative io colleghi che
mi dicono io non sono un creativo o
persone che vi dicono ho perso la
creatività come se avessero perso il
famoso zainetto na per strada troverete
anche altre persone che esercitano tutti
i giorni un pensiero creativo e non ne
hanno consapevolezza è in cantiere
questo succede sovente sovente vengo
illuminata illuminata da idee da
letture totalmente come posso dire
originali di un problema e di soluzioni
e non è soltanto tecnica la tecnica
c'entra relativamente
ma allora come si raggiunge come si
esercita la creatività come si raggiunge
la consapevolezza
la creatività si allena con l'esperienza
e utilizzato allenarsi come se si
trattasse di un muscolo che va
esercitato tutti i giorni
esperienza che ovviamente fare e rifare
ripetere sperimentare contaminare
allenare l'istinto e mille altre cose
queste due ragazzetti né di periferia
siamo la mia sorella gemella e dio
gemelle di quelle più identiche quindi
leggete una situazione tipo stesso
oratorio stesso coro stessa squadra di
pallavolo stessa scuola stessa classe
fino alla quinta liceo scientifico cioè
fino a quando per fortuna poi abbiamo
potuto scegliere ciascuna il proprio
percorso di studi è anche il proprio
guardaroba che non è una cosa così
scontata
non siamo gemelli inquietanti non
abbiamo poteri paranormali non siamo
telepatiche semplicemente siamo due
persone che da grandi fanno mestieri che
sono ritenuti creativi
vi parlo di noi perché negli ultimi
vent'anni le nostre vite si sono così
tanto diversificate allontanate che noi
pur facendo lavori ritenuti creativi
abbiamo un approccio al foglio bianco
sanamente è completamente opposto nulla
di nuovo sotto il sole ovvio però sto
cercando di fissare un idea nonostante
un background praticamente identico
nonostante un imprinting sostanzialmente
fotocopiato il nostro approccio creativo
speriamo lo sia non è assolutamente le
stesso e l'esperienza che ha puntato il
nostro modo di concepire la creatività
uso questa foto non per parlare di noi
ma per fissare un idea come me e mia
sorella
la creatività e plurale si manifesta in
modo più ora le in ciascuno di noi in
modo diverso attiva meccanismi
completamente diversi
si nutre di diversità ha bisogno della
diversità per credere la creatività ha
bisogno di sentirsi più rari e ce lo
dice lei creatività si scrive
allo stesso modo sia il singolare che
altro la naturale e questo certamente
non è un caso
ora
in architettura qualunque processo
architettonico la complessità di
qualunque cantiere non è mai frutto di
individualità mai
l'architetto da solo non fa nulla non
crea nulla architetto e propulsore di un
processo in cui subentra un numero tale
di figure di competenze e dunque anche
di creatività enorme quindi l'architetto
può essere propulsore
dell'architettura ma non è mai padrone e
l'architetto deve in qualche modo
accogliere tutte queste creatività che
spesso sono inconsapevoli
come dicevo prima e talvolta restano
anonime
per la creatività se davvero è una
competenza con che cosa deve fare i
conti con lo spazio col tempo e con la
fiducia con lo spazio non è difficile
immaginarlo capirlo qualunque problema
qualunque invenzione può essere in
qualche modo ingabbiata circoscritta in
uno spazio della mia delimitato e
delineato in cui confini non sono
necessariamente dei limiti sono degli
stimoli architettura certa di plasmare
lo spazio cerca di leggerlo di
interpretarlo e quindi di conseguenza la
creatività che l'accompagna fa lo stesso
lavoro
cercando di essere fedele a quello che
ho detto all'inizio e non parlare di
grandi maestri oggi vi parlerò di un
grande creativo che è il signor pino
signor pino e un muratore
verità è una persona cui non ho mai
conosciuto
ri strutturava un appartamento
ottocentesco volevo ripristinare un
camino di cui era a conoscenza
cammino che era stato chiuso e dopo un
pochino di ricerche facciamo breccia
all'interno del muro e che cosa troviamo
troviamo adagiati nella camera del
camino tutti i marmi tutti i fregi tutte
le terracotte che componevano il cammino
ottocentesco
ora immaginiamoci la scena il signor
pino incaricato di chiudere questo
cammino all'inizio del novecento deve
essersi sentito dire delle cose che io
sento sovente mi raccomando pino faccia
in fretta che può deve costare il meno
possibile in faccia polvere
cos'è che io proprio davvero senso
frequentemente nella mia esperienza e
pino che cosa fece circo scrisse il
problema allo spazio veramente piccolo e
delimitato di un focolare e le risorse
ha certamente con un pensiero non
lineare non ha fatto quello che
avrebbero fatto tutti gli altri
avrebbero pronte frantumato tutto è
riempito secchi fatto le scale eccetera
eccetera in questi termini pino è un
creativo inconsapevole è una persona che
ha attuato messo in atto un pensiero
alternativo ed è stato un uomo che ha
avuto visione deve aver pensato a un
certo punto che le cose e le case quindi
ci superano vivono c sopravvivono vivono
più a lungo di noi e chi era lui per
precludere a qualcun altro la
possibilità di ripristinare quel camino
e di rimetterla al suo posto e così
cento anni dopo quel camino è tornato al
suo posto il tempo che qui vi ho
raccontato come visione e l'altro
aspetto con cui si confronta la
creatività spesso il pensiero creativo
più puro e
una reazione istintiva
istantanea ad un problema
esattamente come è stato per gino questa
volta parliamo di un idraulico
un cantiere in un giorno qualunque si
verifica una perdita di gas è
generalmente in questi casi si
interviene immediatamente
poggiando uno straccio bagnato sulla
perdita questo è utile nel caso ne abbia
sentito il bisogno per qualche motivo lo
straccio in cantiere non c'era abbiamo
cercato tutti abbiamo iniziato a correre
e tutti tranne gino gino è rimasto fermo
gino istantaneamente l'idraulico decide
di togliersi la maglietta di bagnarla e
di metterla sulla perdita
ora alla frase di idraulico si toglie la
maglietta qualcuno potrebbe aver
santificato ma la realtà supera la
fantasia gina non era esattamente un
fotomodello però era un creativo forse
un creativo inconsapevole pesato una
persona che ha avuto una reazione che
qualcuno può dire ovvia ma non c'è
niente di ovvio visto che tutti gli
altri me compreso non abbiamo fatto la
stessa cosa io sono corso giù per le
scale dai vicini nel disperato tentativo
di recuperare lo straccio
la terza e ultima categoria con quale
con la quale la creatività si confronta
e la fiducia non la fiducia degli altri
bensì quella che chi esprime un pensiero
creativo deve dare alla creatività deve
garantire
avete sentito parlare dell'effetto
dunning kruger che è una sorta di corto
circuito mentale per cui
chi è incompetente tendenzialmente non
si rende conto di essere incompetente
mentre chi nel corso della sua vita ha
accumulato esperienza e dunque
competenza a un certo punto inizia
dubitarne perché conosce la complessità
della materia in cui lavora
succede a me ve lo dico e così è vero è
una seria verissima la creatività per
esprimersi per essere espressa ha
bisogno di fiducia da parte di chi
esprime il pensiero creativo
in architettura in modo assoluto la
creatività ha bisogno di fiducia e la
fiducia è l'unica strada per raggiungere
la consapevolezza quella che è mancata a
pino ea gino
ora perché ho fatto tutto questo
racconto in questo modo in questi
termini perché intanto non volevo che
l'architettura fosse
un ennesima per un'ennesima
volta trattata come qualcosa di lontano
l'architettura è sotto di noi sopra dino
intorno a noi ci confrontiamo
costantemente con l'architettura ci
misuriamo nell'architettura e quindi ho
voluto un po farvi questo racconto un
pochino più esperienziale per arrivare a
trarre una conclusione che secondo me
può essere generale
in qualunque complessità di un cantiere
di un'architettura in qualunque progetto
come ho detto prima dal cucchiaio alla
città da costruire la cuccia del cane
fino all'aquilone il regalo più grande
che possiamo farci è quello di metterci
in ascolto e di imparare a riconoscere a
riconoscere la creatività che ci sta
intorno
solo in questo modo saremo in grado di
costruire
connessioni importanti capaci di
attivare una ferita ancora più profonda
una creatività che continuerà a farci
divertire
quando affrontiamo le sfide quelle
professionali e quelle della vita e a
proposito del divertirsi a insane ha
detto la creatività e l'intelligenza che
si diverte e secondo me è una frase una
citazione che descrive benissimo la
magia di quello che avviene un cantiere
grazie
[Applauso]